so how about that avatar the first
season finally throw it god it's like
just went like that didn't it so I am
wrapping up the first season with the
this two-part episode the siege of the
north and as episodes go it is good it's
it's a good way to finish off you know
the first season the problems I have
with it I'll say right now begin because
it is good the problems I have with it I
have to admit I only have with it
because this show has done so well in
having such a high standard and has
probably raised the bar a great deal as
well um because if this stuff happened
in any other kids show I probably won't
give a shit but the fact that it's done
in a show that they've established so
well uh I think it's worth bringing up
so I guess one thing is that the
criticisms here are actually take it as
a compliment these criticisms it makes
it because that it's usually because it
is so strong that I feel it's we're
talking about um you know my brother's
saw the the this the end of this first
season here before me he's starting to
watch the show - he's all ahead of me
and he said you know the blast the
two-parter it's good but it's it's
rushed and I'll start watching and not
entirely knowing what he was talking
about but when it was all said and done
and now I do know what he's talking
about because there are good aspects in
here and I'm not gonna act like it was
totally emotionally devoid you know if
it wasn't there there's good scenes but
I'll admit I was not as invested in this
massive big climax as I was in other
episodes I think this was supposed to be
like the really big climax and I think
the reason for that was bright is if
they gave it if they took out one of the
other filler episodes and I'm not
against filler episodes are really not
if but if they maybe took out one of
those and replaced it with a
quote-unquote filler episode in the noir
poll to set up a little bit more some of
this stuff I think it would have had a
much bigger impact but the problem is
that there's a lot of times where it's
like a lot of exposition is thrown at
you in these two episodes and on top of
that they're supposed to be this
emotional connection that happens
between between Sokka and the princess
character and it's not it's not that
isn't there it's that it sort of has to
be juggled in with everything else and
there could have been more time devoted
to it so that I guess um you saw the
episode when she sacrifices herself at
the end it's not like a huge loss it
that should be a huge loss and if there
was another episode to devote time to
that relationship and not the dumbass
triangle I hate I hate love triangles
when they're done for drama never work
when does one worked I I can never
remember one working it if there is one
I haven't seen it yet or maybe it's not
in my memory but they were great in
comedies because that creates very funny
conflict but man do they not work in in
any drama romance because you know
they're either gonna get together or
it's going to end in tragedy why can't
they just get together and even if it
does ended tragedy why can't they just
have a relationship that blooms and they
come across the problems with
relationship or the problems and being
different people the privates like why
not a real fucking relationship I again
that that's something minor it that's
tapping into something I really hate it
love triangles um so so that was one
aspect another aspect is that there's
these spirits like the Spirit of the
Moon and the spirit of I think the ocean
uh that are in the human world and the
Avatar finds out and he has to go search
for them and he has to go into the
spirit world and sphere was awesome and
there's this really cool Oh what the
hell's the name of that face stealer
thing what a great concept I love that
the face stealer it's just a an egg like
here's what the vagueness I think
actually works is he had to be careful
they doesn't steal your face
you don't quite know what's going on you
just know that this thing that's a great
design it's like this caterpillar spider
with a vagina that spits out different
faces pretty much every was a lot about
the penis due in the last airbender
movie they never talk about the vagina
with the faces in it um but so this
thing comes up and you can tell that
he's trying to steal the face he sir
going up to him almost like he's trying
to catch him off guard but Aang is
keeping very cool and he's keeping very
polite and thank you for revealing
yourself yes I understand you can tell
that he's keeping some sort of distance
and you don't quite know how it works
but you know something is going on with
both of them and I surprisingly like
that that vagueness it kind of leaves it
open like well yeah what was going on
there what were they doing you just know
it's something mental because they never
actually touch each other so so that was
fun um and I said the spirit world was
gracing that again uh actually in more
detail seeing the spirit world some of
the creatures whatever that albino
monkey thing was whether I what I love
that guy I hope he comes back
um and so that's going on and we find
out that these uh these waterbenders
they get their power from the moon and
firebenders get their power from the Sun
okay that that makes sense for the
firebending why why does the moon cuz it
makes the water colder I don't know the
here's the thing the guy general Malfoy
guy blots out the mone he gets rid of
the spirit which destroys the moon again
you don't didn't quite know this is how
it works but okay I guess you'll sort of
take it and then you find out like
literally as all this chaos is happening
the princess is like you know oh I owe
my life to the spirits what what are you
talking about well you see when I was
born it's like there's a fucking battle
going on down there man it's like
shouldn't we be like okay let's discuss
strategies let's not you know it's yeah
I know the story's gonna come in later
but why don't you could you've said this
earlier can we move the seat up Clint
than something sheesh
with Sokka earlier another developmental
scene instead of this dummies love
triangle that really seems to go nowhere
it um is so so that's going on and
obviously she's the one that I guess
saves the day
somehow ish sacrificing her life ish um
her life fish for the fish and I don't
know if again I I always gotta be
careful good people are like it's got me
back they're gonna talk about later so
maybe they are but as of now I am
confused um I don't know exactly what
happened there it's like the spirit gave
her something so she can live and now
she's giving that back to give back the
life of the fit could the fish not die
if she didn't turn the hair white if it
even is a she I mean you never see what
they are um so so you got that going on
and then you also have a was the other
thing uh the again not to go into the
love triangle but even the jerky
boyfriend cuz that's all he is and as
he's just the jerky boyfriend um is so
forgettable
even as forgettable jerky boyfriends go
this one is so forgettable there's a
scene that made me it is a hilarious
scene uh if I liked really hard this
scene where the boyfriend he sneaks in
he's behind the general Malfoy guy it
takes off the mask and shows a easy you
know not one of the soldiers aces your
time has come
runs after him the general moves out of
the way throws him off the balcony so as
I was saying the moon's gonna blot out
and they never refer to him again like
they never referenced this kid ever
again and that's it's it's funny as hell
it is so funny that they would just
dismiss this character that quickly
there's not even a guard sees him he's
just gone and you know on the one hand
that is hilarious um but really you need
a love triangle for that was he really
so forgettable you don't it doesn't even
matter what happened to him after that I
mean that's he was he really that much
of a plot device
and the answer is yes again unless it
does he come back does he come back say
you took my fiancee who actually gave
her I can't see the plane bring him back
but maybe they'll find something if they
do I don't know as a now that seemed
pretty pointless um and again I like
alexhuchet
in disguise I like the fight with the
general I really like that once the
general is being sucked in by the what
of that Mononoke monster thing that egg
turns into um after the generals being
sucked in even as Zuko and him were
fighting he still says give me your hand
and he still wants to help him and of
course the general being the typical
Patterson saying I will not you know it
pulls his hand back and say you know
that's I love because that's like even
more baggage for Zuko it's just like
everybody rejects him it's like even his
enemy even when he hands hands out you
know the only person that will help this
person the the rejection is so strong
the general won't even take the hand to
save his life I I love that stuff it's
so fucking sick I love it it's just the
more you can beat on this character you
know what and and it is sick but I think
the reason we like those kind of scenes
in those kind of characters is because
you know it now he doesn't create more
to identify but I think for the Zuko
character they're trying to build up
more and more for him to really redeem
himself and to come back and the more
and more you see stuff is hammering down
on him and in different various ways the
more he'll be hurt but the more he can
crawl out of it I think that is service
ID it's like well you know the deeper
you dig yourself it is the further you
have to dig out but you can still dig
out uh and if anything you're all the
more proud when you do it so I think
honestly even though it's still kind of
disturbing that we do like those scenes
uh I think that's why maybe uh because I
can't see them just making like you know
yeah there goes a bad
and that's it no they're developing him
pretty well and I'll give credit to the
guide is a general Malfoy guy's voice um
again for a character that's written
kind of as a pretty straightforward
villain I like the way this voice actor
is really sucking in the glory like when
he has aura preaching the glory I should
say when he has the spirit in the bag
that sounds weird sounds like a song or
something like a gorilla song um you
know he has the the spirit in the bag
and he's just like you know I I have
done it I have you know destroyed the
moon they're gonna write stories about
me I have made history I I mean it's
like it's really sinking in for him and
I like that because it gives a little
bit more dimension and well then so much
easier if he Greta said I did I write
stories about me in history I've
destroyed the moon haha and I really
like that they played it more quiet
during such a big scene I thought that
was really cool
um and the the battle is really cool you
know at every time the Fire Nation is
attacking I want to hear the orc theme
oh I hear doctor doctor uh you get to
see more of those tanks um none of the
balloons I thought those were gonna show
up but I am a they didn't may not have
time was allowed to make that I don't
know that they're building that up you
know like hey here's a really you know
this is now our victory cuz we can take
flight um and I didn't show up here
maybe I'll show up later again I you
just assume if I say something doesn't
show up I'm always leaving it open to it
might show up later because I'm not done
with I'm so used to reviewing movies
it's like well this is it um you know
you see the movie that's you know and
there's they may make a sequel but what
do you think of the movies so um so I
never know if there's gonna be more of
it but about know everything okay so
they get the power from the moon alright
but once the moon is like covered and
then taken out it's like their powers
just vanish there's still the friggin
water you know the this Fire Nation I
mean they can they can still attack at
night I mean they're not as powerful
they can make fire I mean they have to
make the damn stuff the water is fucking
right there why can they not use this I
don't get that um yeah you know I'm not
entirely sure how that works I mean it's
like the moon can may play a part but
the water it's the water its water
bending not bending the light of the
moon in water right so I bet seem weird
to me but again that that's nitpicking I
suppose um so yeah it seems like it's
not that they tried to do too much per
se I actually think it's it's a good
chunk and it's a fair amount I think
they just need one more episode to
establish this stuff to move it out or
to spread it out I think if they did
that they would have if they made this a
three parter we probably would have had
like a really good Olli shit what a
climax like this could have been like
one of the great episodes but but it's
still good episode you know it still has
the character still has the discovery
still has a revealing a bunch of stuff
about how this world works and how the
avatar works in the spirit world and
stuff and it has good action in it um
I'm trying to think what else I like the
ones get I'll get his name but I like
the uncle ah Zucco's uncle I like I like
it when he steps up in battle which is
there's never a doubt that he will but
it always feels good when he does it
because you get the idea that he's
someone that like he'll fight for his
honor but he likes to stay more in the
sidelines like he's kind of an old man
and he has his ethics and he I'm curious
why he's in the Fire Nation because his
ethics don't always fall to what their
ethics are and I'm really fascinated by
that I'd love to know more about what
the connection between those two
brothers are you know the the Fire Lord
and and the uncle um I love to know
exactly I mean the the Fire Lord is
pretty obvious that's like you know um
tilda on hitler's IV did dictator rule
the world guy um I'm curious what the
uncle's mind said is because he doesn't
seem like someone who should be there
you know Zuko is sort of going through a
change but at the same time you know it
what the hell from his uncle too but the
same time you can see he comes from his
father you know this is where this has
come from and then him be more in the
world and not his own and again under
the the health alive his uncle he he's
getting a better stronger heart becoming
more honorable but what it's almost like
why I really am questioning why the
uncle is in this fire nation uh or if
he's planning something or I I don't
know I'm curious about that um by
starting that to mash up so but maybe
they'll play a part maybe they'll leave
the Fire Nation who knows maybe they'll
be like it seems like they're building
that up that they're gonna be like you
know what fuck the Fire Nation we're
gonna do our own thing I mean that'd be
my guess or maybe uncle dies or
something so goes like I have a counter
Fire Nation not now just speculate I
really don't know may they stay there
forever
he becomes the new bad guy who knows so
I'm just rambling now but Stu episode so
this this view was probably twice as
long so it was a good finale and it was
not great and it could have been great
but it was still good and obviously a
lot effort went into it and and they
took advantage of all that they could do
with the waterbending and the
firebending and I like um I liked that
one guy that the teacher who he does
this cool move where he gets all the
water it's like a water tornado and
stuff I like that now Katara is
technically a master now waterbending
master that's great I'm glad it wasn't
like well we had to go through episodes
and episodes of this is like no she she
picked it up and you can see she fucking
picked it out cuz she was like you know
given this guy a run for his money of
the episode before so I like that now um
and uh yeah
I think that's about all I got in this
episode so that's about it I can't wait
to see where the next season goes
I'll see in the next season